this is a production of Cornell
University
Thanks you're going to lower the lights
because some of the slides I think will
show up better thank you class and I'd
like to thank class for inviting me to
talk with you today this is my very
first plant biology seminar and I'm
happy to have the opportunity to tell
you about some of our work now in the
title I include the word art of you know
art and science because I've found over
the years that you're working on plant
tissue culture and transformation
there's definitely an art to it there is
a field experience for what should be
done next and there's also a lot of
creativity involved but you know as I
think about it I think the same is true
for other areas of research as well so
these are some points that I'm going to
cover doing a during my presentation
I'll give you some background on tissue
culture and plant transformation I
thought giving you some of the basics
would be you know really good before I
launched into how we develop the methods
and giving you examples of the projects
Lisa Earle his class mentioned I did my
graduate work in her lab and before her
retirement she taught an entire class on
tissue culture and transformation so I
have just a few slides I think you know
kind of put you on that level so you
understand why we do what we do I'll use
these current projects as examples of
how we develop those methods grape is
the most recent one in our lab we've
been working with Anurag agrawal in at
Cornell and Asclepius and also his class
mentioned we're working with setaria
veredus which is a c4 photosynthesis
grass that we're developing as a model
species and then I'll end by telling you
some of the next steps up for those
projects so let's see it there are four
components to development of these
methods there's the plant tissue culture
and plant regeneration even before we go
into transformation we have to have an
efficient method for plant regeneration
and these are some examples so this is
potato so for potato we start with
plants that are grown in tissue culture
in test tubes which is referred to as in
vitro and we put those stem pieces on a
medium that induces this growth called
calais which is an unorganized massive
cells someone analogous to a tumor and
then we tweak that medium to give the
cells the signal to produce plants and
these little potato plants are then room
moved from the callous and transferred
to a rooting medium this is tomato
tomato we start with cotyledon pieces
that from seedlings that are grown in
culture and these are all examples of
plant regeneration after transformation
so you'll see that not every piece of
plant materials regenerating shoots and
then for setaria we start with callous
that is induced from mature seeds and
I'm going to tell you about that in more
detail later and this is what we use for
the transformation and again that
callous is put on to regeneration medium
to induce these plants to grow once we
have you know a good system worked out
for the plant tissue culture then we
move into the gene transfer methods a
critical part of this and can sometimes
be a stumbling block is in the routing
and acclimation to greenhouse conditions
we of course work all this out before we
even try gene transfer methods and
patients and lots of patience it takes a
long time to go from start to finish and
as you'll see when I talk about grape
we're sometimes working with very small
plant material that we have to use a
dissecting scope in order to do the work
so we start with the working out a new
method will first go to the literature
to see if anything has been reported for
that particular plant species if we
don't find anything then we look to see
what is the most you know the most
closely related relative see if there's
anything reported for that if you don't
find anything which happens sometimes we
then go based on experience and also a
lot of trial and error to find out the
best combination to use so for plant
material we have a number of choices but
for monocots what works best are
immature inflorescences mature seeds and
immature embryos for dicots you can
pretty much try any one of these types
of plant material one part where we do
spend quite a bit of time also is
working out methods to clean up that
material now that culture medium I
showed you in the slides contains sugar
because they need a carbon source since
they're growing in laboratory conditions
and if you don't clean up that material
there a lot of material be overgrown by
bacteria and fungi and it will kill the
material so we use bleach ethanol
sometimes a thief
angle antibacterial compounds but
there's really a fine line sometimes
between finding the right method that
will clean up the contaminants yet not
kill the plant material if some of these
systems are easier than others but for
something like for the Asclepius we
spent a lot of time trying to find the
best method for cleaning up the material
for culture medium components not every
medium contains all these components
it's just an example of what you can
include in the medium the major part of
the medium it can either salt
formulations and those salts are like
nitrogen phosphorus potassium whatever
is needed to support plant growth and
culture there are a number of standard
salt formulations that we use one common
one is called machete and skoog or ms
but there are even modified versions of
ms so you can find you can purchase an
MS medium that doesn't contain any
ammonium nitrate because some plant
species are sensitive to the ammonium
nitrate so there are a lot of parts to
those salts that can also affect the
plant material one of the most critical
parts of the medium are these plant
growth regulators and there are two
categories are auxins and cytokinins and
these are an example of some auxins and
these are some excited Heinen's so we're
working with these methods it's not only
the choice of an oxen or cytokine and
that can make a difference it's the
combination it's the concentration it's
the ratios sometimes we'll start out in
an oxen but then move to a cytokine and
so it really depends on the plant
species that we're working with for a
carbohydrate source sucrose is the most
common but we do work with some systems
where a malt toast or glucose works
better gelling agents there are
different types of augers and gellan gum
and sometimes it's really hard to
convince people that gelling agent can
really make a difference I think some
people think it's just not an important
part of the medium until we give them a
protocol and we say you have to use you
know a gellan Gum to start out with even
though it's in bold it in its red and
then they'll contact me and they'll say
the methods not working and so all right
let's start troubleshooting and then I
find out that they substituted the
gelling agent that we didn't recommend a
big mouth really trust me you know the
gelling agent can make a difference
they're also amino acid
vitamins that are sometimes required
activated charcoal kind of lie acts like
an antioxidant when some of the plant
material will turn brown when we cut it
and put it in culture and the activated
charcoal helps absorb that it also
absorbs inhibitors that might prevent
plant regeneration and I you know worked
at geranium when I was at Sanford's and
when we would cut the pieces of geranium
and put them on culture they would just
turn black so we ended up looking at a
number of different types of
antioxidants and concentrations in order
to prevent that the you know the
phenolic from taking down the material
and there's also coconut water now I
don't see this as you know often now in
recent literature but in the earlier
days coconut water is used and you can
still purchase coconut water through
some of the companies and it contains
you know a number of sugars growth
regulators amino acids and some
undefined components that really can
make a difference in getting plant
regeneration or not getting it now in
developing a transformation method where
we spend the majority of our time is in
the plant regeneration phase we don't
start plant transformation until we feel
that the regeneration part is very
efficient and when I would recommend is
that at least thirty to forty percent of
your plant material or regenerating
shoots and that's because when you do an
agrobacterium infection not every cell
is infected so if you have a system
that's for generating a lot of shoots
you have a greater chance of recovering
transformants in the end so that's why I
would say if you have something that's
less than thirty percent don't even try
it until you get that percentage up so
right there are three different methods
that you can use for transformation
agrobacterium biol istics of the gene
gun and as I'm class mentioned the gene
gun was invented here at Cornell and
basically what happens is there are
micron size particles Boulder tungsten
that are coated with DNA and blasted
into the plant cells there's also a DNA
uptake into protoplasts if you have a
leaf you treat it with enzymes that
takes away the cell wall your left at
the protoplast and
and there are methods to increase that
DNA uptake into the protoplast in our
lab we use agrobacterium for all of our
work we find that it works perfectly
fine it's a soil borne bacterium about
30 years ago a group of scientists
decided that since agrobacterium is
engineering plants in nature it
transfers genes into plant cells to
produce the metabolites that it needs to
growth you can they take that bacterium
from the soil and use it in the lab to
transfer genes of interest and it worked
and that was like the whole start of
plant biotechnology from there the
number of reports was increased
dramatically there are different strains
that you need to consider when you're
doing the transformation you need to
think of it and I've know in a plant
pathogen interaction there are
antibiotics depending on the strain that
you're using that eventually will
eliminate that bacterium because if we
don't do that after a transformation the
agrobacterium over grows the material
and kills it and there's also different
phases of growth we need to look at and
concentrations so after we when we make
an overnight culture of agrobacterium
will read the optical density and in
general it's about a point 62.7 but for
some species we found we have to
decrease that by 10 times so reason 8.06
or point no 7 because it's just very
sensitive to the agrobacterium now
vectors this can really make or break a
plant transformation system those are
the shuttles that were used in the
agrobacterium to transfer the DNA into
the cells we use on electroporation
there are different methods that you can
use to introduce that plasmid DNA and
that vector but we find that electro /
ation works just fine for us there are
different selectable marker genes and
I'm going to go into more detail on this
when I talk about vectors and those are
genes that confer resistance to
antibiotic and also herbicide and then
we include those components either an
antibiotic or herbicide in component
into our medium and there are different
types and concentrations and you have to
get timing and you know there's a lot of
parts of this that you need to look at
for your particular plant species when
we're working out a new method will use
something called a reporter gene we
don't jump in to just start using our
gene of interest because sometimes genes
of interest can have a negative effect
on the regeneration of plants it affects
the development so we start out with
these reporter genes there's one called
Gus which is beta coupe you're on
today's and the way this works is that
if you have this in your vector you do
your transformation the plants you
recover you can take pieces of leaves
put them into an assay solution if it
turns blue it's successful if not its
back to the drawing board and there's
also the green fluorescent protein gfp
the nice thing about gfp is it as
compared to gus when you put your
material and gus it kills it but with
gfp you can actually monitor the
progress of that transformation by using
a fluorescence scope and we're starting
to use more gfp construct vectors in our
lab now and then on the other part of
the agro bacterium is the length of time
with the aggregate with it um when we're
doing a transformation that we have
those pieces of potato stem pieces
they're just dipped 45 minutes and used
to be in the older protocols they would
leave that material in for half an hour
but that ends up having a negative
effect it stresses the plant material so
we find that a five minute dip is
perfectly fine and then it goes back on
to the medium for two to three days and
that's when the agrobacterium attaches
to the cells and does the gene transfer
at that point most often it's in the
dark we do all of our co cultivation in
the dark but there are some reports
where they use light and it's also the
temperature during that period is also
important it's not surprising that
around 19 to 22 degrees Celsius works
best because again it is a soil
bacterium that's how it evolved and we
find that we've done comparisons of
temperatures and found that that range
on works the best ok so for vectors this
is are some examples of vectors and the
peak can be one is a more complicated
diagram is showing the restriction
enzymes that can be used for cloning
and then I have a more simplified vector
down here called panic this was
developed for switchgrass or panicum
that's what i call panic and we've been
using these panic vectors for setaria
you can see that on this plasmid DNA
there's this segment here that I'll
discuss a little bit more in the next
slide and then on that backbone there
are also a bacterial resistance gene for
kanamycin and also this origin of
replication this origin of replication
can also be very important depending on
what plant species you're working on and
we found that to be true for su tarea
this is a closer view of a vector and
what you see here is there is a left and
a right border and though that's the
sequence that the agrobacterium
recognizes agrobacterium has ended
nucleases and those are the sequences it
recognizes to cut that DNA at those
points and transfer it into the plant
cells those vectors also contain
promoters I'm just using these as an
example there's all sorts of different
types of vectors that you can use this
is the NOS promoter driving the npt to
gene now the npt to gene is a selectable
marker gene and it confers resistance to
kanamycin the antibiotic so when we do
our transformation will put the ax
kanamycin into the medium and the reason
we do that is your implant so they were
doing a tomato transformation and we
have cotyledon pieces just about every
cell in that cotyledon has the potential
to go on and to make plants and with a
selectable marker gene only the cells
that receive that npt to gene go on to
make plants because we have kanamycin in
the medium if we didn't do that we would
have a lot of plants to screen in order
to find those few that are really
transformed and it can also affect the
efficiency of the system so we do need
to include a selectable marker gene and
again it could be for antibiotic
resistance or herbicide resistance this
is another promoter that is a common one
called 35s you could put your gene of
interest here I've put gusts there
that's what we use for developing
methods we then electroporated that into
agrobacterium we grow an overnight
culture and we do a transformation
experiment so these are some tools of
the trade for doing that there's
overnight cultures we do the
electroporation we've played it onto the
medium we use toothpicks to transfer
those colonies into the liquid medium
this is a freshly inoculated culture it
goes on to a shaker overnight and then
hopefully it you get growth and then we
take this solution centrifuge it down we
get a pellet and we wash it with a plant
tissue culture medium because the salts
that are used for growing the bacteria
are much to concentrate it and can have
a negative effect on the plant material
so we wash that pallet with a
plant-based culture medium the next week
as I mentioned we'll work out the
routing and acclimation to the
greenhouse even before we do
transformation we certainly don't want
to be working out this out with our
precious transgenic lines we always we
prefer that we get the routing in
culture before we transfer it to soil we
sometimes need to use a lower salt
formulation auxins something like tomato
we don't need to use any oxen in the
rooting medium because it roots readily
and now also we are there some systems
where we use activated charcoal because
if we don't see rooting there might be
an inhibitor there that's causing it to
not root so we'll use activated charcoal
for the acclimation to the greenhouse
there are a number of factors to
consider and not surprising soil type
lighting your different plant species
that we work with we have to use
different types of soil and you'll see
that these are some superior plants that
are covered with water bottles and the
reason that they're covered is that when
we take plants out of culture you know
they're in test tubes or they're in
magenta boxes and which are a culture
vessel that we use and there's a one
hundred percent humidity and the cuticle
isn't well developed the Stowe mates are
wide open and if we transfer those to
soil and we don't cover them they'll
wilt and die so we have been using
plastic bags in the beginning but then
someone had the idea that you know
people in elaborate drinking water we're
having about water and gatorade so we
thought let's
try those and we cut the bottoms off the
bottles we cover the plans after a few
days we'll simply remove the cap and
then after a few days more we'll take
off the bottle and then we wash those
bottles and reuse them so it's much
better than plastic bags because it was
difficult to use the plastic bags we had
to cut holes in the bags to gradually
acclimate them and then discard this bag
so now we have a good supply of bottles
in the lab so this is the a listing of
the plants that we have worked with and
those that are current the those listed
in the black text are those which are
current projects those in red text or
ones that we're doing transformation as
a service so in my group I have support
from bt I for two and a half two and a
half people to do transformations as a
service and the way this works is if
someone is interested today in tomato
like Jim we do a lot of work for Jim it
will give us the construct and we'll do
the transformations into tomato and then
will you know give them the plants back
for their work and it's bait is our fee
recovery system is we have to repay that
loan back to VT I for what that you know
the money that they give us to support
this service component but then the
other projects in the lab are funded
through different funding agencies and
these in blue text or ones that we have
worked on on the past but there are no
longer active projects so I thought you
might be wondering like how long does
the whole process take from when i do
the infection until I can get plants
back and when we do our transformations
as a service people who really anxious
to get the plants back and you know we
do our best to be able to repair to give
them the plants and then they want to
know how long it takes so from the time
safer tomato that we do an infection of
the cotyledon pieces it takes about six
weeks to go from the infection phase to
having these little shoots regenerating
then we transfer those shoes to rooting
medium and if you're interested in fruit
it takes about a total time of five to
six months to recover red ripe fruit if
you're interested in just looking at the
plans for disease or in sectors
Spence yeah it's obviously it's a much
shorter time for potato it's roughly the
same time frame this month difference
here is because some potatoes take
longer in the greenhouse to produce
tubers but again we start with infecting
plant potatoes stem pieces and then in
about eight weeks we have these little
potato plants that we can cut in route
and then we'll put them into the
greenhouse and produce two Burzum in
pots but again if you're just interested
in the plants it's so much a much
shorter time frame so that's it for your
instruction I'm plant tissue culture and
transformation and now I'm going to jump
into the three projects to use those as
an example of how we develop those
methods so as I mentioned grape is one
of the most recent projects that we have
in the lab and I wanted to work on
grapes since we started the
transformation service especially
knowing that grape is such an important
crop in new york state and that i found
that you know just work going on in
geneva and I thought we could really
help help those projects along so this
started as a collaboration with jan wan
and geneva and he suggested that we work
with to model grape plants one is called
pixie it's a dwarf vine and these were
developed to help you know help
accelerate the great breeding program
instead of having to go out to the field
and working with vines in the field
these lines can be grown in the
greenhouse pixie stays small it's a
sport of Pinot Noir and the reason it's
short it's because it's you know there's
a it's a mutant GA I mutant and it
affects the gibberellin pathway so these
plants stay small the internodes are
very close really dark green green
leaves Scout is an experimental line
that was released by the USDA and ARS in
2010 it flowers continuously in the
field in greenhouse so you can see how
this would be an advantage for research
programs you have a continuous supply of
flowers it was developed by a cross
between ruby red and in
and Asian species and this is the make
up here of the scalp and then Gangwon
also recommended that we start working
with concord because it's again it's an
important one in New York State and
that's often used to make jellies and
jams and if you're interested in reading
more about pixie and scout there is a
publication that was put out by Cornell
that describes the background on that
plant material so for grape there are
two possible sources based in the
literature on for starting plant cell
cultures the one is immature in
fluorescence and that is what works best
for wine grapes and some others this
method for the leaves from plants in
vitro does not work for the grapes
they're used for winemaking but it's
mostly seedless grape types that work
through this method but again not all of
them and I'll show you why their
advantages to be using the leaf system
as compared to the immature
inflorescence system so we've been doing
our work based on reports by gray and
dekhni we start by inducing callus on
the plant material and then we look for
something called somatic embryos there
are two methyl two ways where plant
regeneration can happen there's a
somatic embryogenesis and an organo
genesis I'll show you examples of
organogenesis later but for grape it's
through the somatic embryogenesis melkam
mode and when we started this we ended
up testing 14 different media
formulations based on what we found in
the literature to find something to work
for scout and conquer we're not doing
pixie yet but for scout and concord we
had to look at different salts different
growth regulators and other media
components once we have that callous and
we have the somatic embryos the somatic
embryos or se are transferred to a
maintenance medium and this maintenance
medium contains a high level of sucrose
sucrose generally is around 20 to 30
grams per liter in a culture medium but
for this medium we needed a higher level
at 60 there are no growth regulators in
the medium and as I mentioned before the
gelling agent can make or break a system
and talking with
Dennis gray he said it's very important
to use this auger called TC auger
throughout the whole system to get a
good response for great ok now here's
the fun part so so these are this is an
immature in fluorescence from scalp and
this is a dime who uses a size reference
so you can imagine with that immature
inflorescence the size of that and what
we end up doing with these is we retreat
the inflorescence with a bleach solution
to clean it up and there's a lot of
dissecting scope work that has to be
done because what we need to do is take
a bud from this inflorescence cut it
open and then take out the inside flower
part and what is most important in this
system is that the filament stay
attached to the anther because that is
where you get the right type of calais
the callus that's going to give you that
embryogenesis it's difficult to keep the
filament with the anther you know and
what we found is by taking out the
entire part here and putting that on the
medium we were much more successful at
keeping the anther with that filament we
put in on a callus induction medium the
callus forms at the connective tissue
and then that callous we again we're
using a dissecting scope and we're
looking for these tiny little white
embryos that pop up these tiny embryos
are then moved to that maintenance and
it's after their proliferation medium
and you can see all these little embryos
these somatic embryos that have come up
this in here these little ones are what
we called a pre embryo and these are the
somatic embryos and it's these somatic
embryos that are used for the
transformation and I'm really fascinated
in a kind of a nerdy way by by embryo by
somatic embryos I think they're really
cute you know they're very white and
it's really is fun to work with the
systems where we're getting somatic
embryos so as I mentioned there's a lot
of work at the scope and this is Kate
pigeon Kate spends a lot of her time you
know taking out the flower parts looking
for the somatic embryos and I asked her
to look at the camera to show that she
can still be smiling after all this now
this scope work but you know talking
with Dennis gray he said that you know
when he gives his protocol to people
and they then say we're having problems
he finds out that they're not using a
scope they're just trying to do it
without using a dissecting scope and
it's an important part of the process so
this is a close-up of some of those
somatic embryos that are on that
proliferation maintenance medium and you
can see these are more because he lose
the term maturer embryos and down here
and this is a close-up these are some of
the pre embryos so what we do to keep
the embryogenic system going is again we
using the scope will select out these
tiny little embryos put them back onto
the medium and this isn't a black
background this is actually the charcoal
in the medium activated charcoal and
then we'll take these embryos for
transformation and then leave these as
you know the source for getting more
embryos for for our work so we haven't
done a transformation yet but we will be
doing one in about three weeks we needed
to be able to bulk up those somatic
embryos until we had enough to do the
transformation and according to people
I've talked with and through the
literature what we're going to do is
we're going to take one gram of the
scout embryos the somatic embryos the
more well-developed ones will take one
gram of those that go into a liquid
medium for two weeks on a shaker and
then that solution is poured through a
sieve the smaller embryos will go back
into a liquid and then will you pick off
those larger embryos and use this for
transformation we're going to use an
agrobacterium string called AGL one AGL
one is what's called a hyper virulent
agrobacterium there are other virulent
agrobacterium out there that you can use
that you can gather you know
transformation but what we found is with
some of those other virulent
agrobacterium that they're really
difficult to eliminate from culture but
we find that with a GL one we get a good
transformation efficiency we don't have
a problem with eliminating the bacterium
and it also results in a lot of plants
that are single copy so it's important
to not have multiple copies and your
transgenic lines if you're introduced
jeans and a geo one that you know we
find that we've got a really high number
of single copy sometimes two copies of
the introduced gene in our plant
material this for the vector we're going
to use the MTT two selectable marker
gene will use gfp because we really want
to monitor the progress and then
grey told me that within a week we
should if it worked we should be able to
see the green fluorescence protein
expression and then we're going to hope
for the best and see what happens before
we can before we can move on so I and
that another method is for doing in
vitro leaves from the plant leaves from
in vitro plants and we decided to use
this for Concord and the reason we
decided to use that for Concord is
because getting a source of immature
inflorescence was difficult they're only
at the right stage one time for you so
again someone in Gangwon scroop would go
out to the field to get those
inflorescences for us jan wan lives in
ithaca he would drive to ithaca at the
end of the day I would meet him out
front of BTI he would hand off the box
at inflorescences and we had that one
shot at getting and trying all this
different media to get it to work so I
started looking the literature to see
what else can be used and it found that
leaves can possibly use as I mentioned
before it's more successful for seedless
grapes but we're going to try it for
Concord and the way this works is we
takin a young shoot from Concord plants
which actually we have now growing in
the greenhouse and then more dissecting
work we go in here and take out the
small apical meristem that April
America's apical meristem goes on to a
medium and when this plant is bigger
we'll go ahead and we'll take those
leaves we put them on in a callus
induction medium and see if we can get
embryos that way this way we can have
more of a supply of material to bulk up
the somatic embryos that we need for our
transformations ok that's great yes
we're at I'll tell you some of the next
steps later we're working on a sleepiest
with honor AAG in at cornell and the
purpose is developed on irad is
interested and you think so your
community would be interested in having
you know milkweed as a model system and
transformation is an important part of
that being a model system he identified
seven different species based on their
chemical composition and their insect
interactions so we started with these
seven different species we really wanted
to be able to
use in vitro grown plants so they would
be clean we wouldn't have to worry about
cleaning up leave for stem material
every time you wanted to do a
transformation but we couldn't get them
to root the milkweed just would not root
and culture and he used to kill me when
I be on a walk and I'd see a milk read
growing in a space between the sidewalk
and a wall like are you kidding me
you're going perfectly fine there and we
can't get you to root and culture so I
could give a whole seminar on what we
tried for routing but we just be gave up
and we said all right we're going to
have to use plant material grown in the
growth chamber or greenhouse for our
starting material cleaning it up was a
challenge it was a challenge finding
that that's kind of sweet spot where it
cleans up the contamination but yet
doesn't kill the plant material there's
nothing more you know disconcerting is
coming in and seeing a fungus growing
all over your plates okay so these are
some images of the species that we're
working with this is the common one that
you might be familiar with that the
monarch butterfly goes through its life
cycle on this is a tuberosa or butterfly
weed and I think they're just they're
beautiful here's some other images I've
actually started a milkweed garden at
home because they're really pretty I
really like the curse a vaca but this is
how we get to see them on a daily basis
these are some of the feminine pieces
that are you making talus on this talus
induction medium we use the scopes to
scan that callous to look for the starts
of plant regeneration to make sure we're
on the right track with everything that
we're trying so when we see something
like this we get really excited because
this is the start of the production of
shoots now unlike grape which is somatic
embryogenesis this is organogenesis and
when we see this we know it we're you
know we're getting to that point where
we could recover plants others sometimes
we're fooled and they're actually roots
that's pretty disappointing but but this
was pretty exciting when we after trying
all sorts of different methods that we
came up with these little these little
shoots so because working with seven
different species was difficult and
plant tissue culture and regeneration
there's a definite genetic component to
it
species even closely related species
they they require different conditions
and culture so we decided to just focus
on the three now that gave us the plant
regeneration first a key part of the
meeting we're using an antioxidant we
use dtt we used an aggravator IAM strain
LBA 40404 this is showing some best
response and the cultures and we've done
on some recent real gene transformations
where we're looking at knocking down
quite one expression and koi one is
involved in defense and right now Amy
who works on the project is doing
characterization to see how far down
that koi one is is knocked down and then
we'll continue doing transformations
with the other species the last project
I'm going to talk about is the setaria
veredus project this started out as a
collaboration with Tom Brunell when he
was at bti and as I mentioned the
interest is because it's a model species
it has a small stature compared to
something like maize sorghum or sugar
cane and it's c4 photosynthesis this is
a phylogeny of the grasses setaria very
distilled it's a wild relative of the
cultivated foxtail millet and it's a
close relative of switchgrass it has a
lot of attributes that make it
attractive for a model species it's a
small stature you can grow a lot of
plants kind of like the Arab adopts ax
so the die-cut world we can grow a lot
of plants in a small area and what
really we need it at this point was to
have a transformation method worked out
and Tom asked me about is interested and
I said definitely you know what it will
take on that on that challenge so what I
did is I went to the literature first to
see what if there was anything reported
revered asst than there wasn't but there
were reports for its cultivated relative
italica and they started with mature
seeds the only problem with veredus is
it there's a dormancy issue if the seeds
are younger than three months old so we
found that we had to break the dormancy
we tried all sorts of methods to break
the dormancy and what worked out the
best was removing the seat coats and
i'll show you in the next couple of
slides how we do that the seeds are then
cultured on
a callus induction medium we then clean
up the coleoptiles and the roots and we
transfer that to fresh medium and as I
mentioned before the importance of
gelling agent when we started out and
the italica reports they use auger in
the medium and what we were getting with
veredus was this really sticky
gelatinous non regenerable callous and
we just we really really want it was
this more defined callous and I knew
from my experience prior experience with
Monica's Pet sometimes a gel n gum in
this case Phi to gel actually works
better and when we switched to that
fight of gel we recovered more of this
more well-defined with general callus
you couldn't ask for anything better for
plant regeneration just about every
piece of callistor generates multiple
shoots we took one shoot and put it on
rooting medium it rude it well it till
ered a lot and you know it's very just
fine so we knew that we were now ready
to do plant transformation so as I
mentioned to remove the seed coats we
came up with this really simple but it
works with chick a tray we have a rubber
stopper we got some Ridge plastic
material out of my kitchen drawers and
we take the seeds and we rub that rubber
stopper over the seeds we were concerned
that maybe would break a lot of the
seeds and wouldn't get good germination
but we got close to a hundred percent
germination and then this is where more
patience comes in those seeds are
selected away from those that have the
seed coats and this is what we use for
the callus induction medium for the
transformation we start it with Lee's
this vector this vector has a gene for
hygromycin resistance npt to and
kanamycin don't work that well for
monocots as compared to dicots we
inspect the callus with the
agrobacterium they then go to a
selective regeneration medium that has
hygromycin in it this is a very happy
day in the lab when we have this is our
non-transformed control we put it in
gusts no blue but when we put one of the
putative transformers into Gus solution
it turns blue and this is showing some
leaf material from a control did not
turn blue and this is some of these are
some leaves from some older transgenic
lines now as I mentioned we use that
selectable marker gene because if we
didn't this is what we would end up
after we did a transformation so we
would have to analyze a lot of plans in
order to find these precious few that
are really transformed we wanted to see
if we could get this to persist into the
next generation so we took something we
let some of those transgenic lines go on
to make seed hear them in the greenhouse
harvested that next generation which is
called the t1 a statham for gus solution
for gus with using essays solution and
you can see again non-transformed
control and gus expression in those
progeny so hit them this is a timeline
for how long the whole process takes
from culturing the seed on calais medium
to having seeds harvested for new
transgenic lines takes about 21 weeks
but if we have that callous already we
could cut off six weeks off that process
and with monocots it's really difficult
to maintain callous long-term and still
have it maintained that Huayra
generality and when you do get
regeneron's you sometimes see a large
percentage of albinos because the
transposons are activated but we decided
to try it with setaria and so far what
we've seen is we're just testing taking
callous keeping it long term and putting
it on regeneration medium and it seems
to be acting differently than maize or
rice callous and that we're not seeing
that hit on plant regeneration and now
we're going to try some of that longer
term callus on for transformation okay
so I'm not I didn't go into I'm not
going to talk about a have time to talk
about our crisper work in setaria but we
have untried genome editing by targeting
this flowering time gene called
indeterminate one and what you can see
here is that these are the controls
empty vector no target in them and these
are two lines that were recovered you
can see there's a definite difference in
the flowering time so that was you know
really good indication phenotypically
that we hit the right gene and it is
working and all of the propel the lines
now both the primary ones and progeny
are being analyzed to see what types of
mutations we had and the few penned the
frequency I know so that has been spent
a lot of fun working with the crisper
coastline
so in summary I hope I've impressed upon
you all the work that it takes sometimes
people don't appreciate it and we do a
transformation servicing like what's
taking so long how can we don't have our
plans that's rare but you know there
really is a lot of work that goes into
the system I have a great group they're
very patient they're very creative and
that's why we are successful in what we
do so for the next step for grape we are
going to do it mentioned the
transformation with gfp as soon as we
have enough embryos from concord we're
going to try transformation of concord
for the Asclepius will characterize
those koi one knockdown lines and trying
to recover more of those so we can have
different levels of expression and
different transgenics improve the
routing and soil we've given up on in
vitro routing and we're looking at
reading in soil it's not great but it's
better than what it used to be they were
also starting to work on the other
species of the seven species for setaria
veredus we're actually looking at other
accessions besides the eight 10.1
because you know i mentioned that
there's a genetic component to plant
regeneration and also for transformation
and that we feel that if we have
confined another accession where we can
get higher than five to twenty percent
transformation efficiency that would
make it more high throughput for us and
as we're looking at the long-term calif
maintenance so that we can cut off about
six weeks off the process and we're
going to expand our genome editing
efforts so right now we're just using it
for a mutagenesis to knock out jeans
what we're looking at some of the new
crisper technologies that have come
along to activate endogenous genes and
do some gene replacement and no systems
and we're doing that both in setaria and
in tomato as well so with that I'll have
acknowledgments this is my group who
made it all possible they're great
patient and just put up with some of my
crazy ideas at Cornell amy is working
with an entourage group she works with
us as well she's very talented this is
gallons group who had been helping us
with the grape the group at danford
center and in Minnesota have been
involved in the crisper work with
setaria and I have a collaboration with
a group of the John Innes Centre and
where some of that funding has helped
support our improvement of setaria
because they're using site area as a
model for that project and these are the
sources of funding very good and thank
you guys medicago takes a long time to
go from start to finish that's one of
the most difficult parts and there's one
genotype that works best so what in the
beginning we had some problems because
they were recommending one of the groups
of recommending using this eh a 105
super virulent as a bacterium and we
lost a lot of material from overgrowth
but when we switched to a gl1 we were
able to eliminate that so as long as
you're working with that one particular
genotype and you're willing to wait for
quite a while at done it's workable it's
doable not as easy as tomato but
yeah you know I basically would have
seen in the reports it's a chemical
composition but also a physical
composition to it exactly like like I'm
Joel right one of the gel rang jo Jo Ann
gums it needs to it binds the divalent
cations magnesium and calcium in order
to gel and I learned this the hard way
when I was a graduate student and I was
trying some experiments with the gelling
agent I thought why should I make up a
whole batch of salt you know meeting
with salts in and I'll just use water
and the gelling agent I couldn't get it
to Joe as a why isn't it showing auger
gels and water and then when I did some
more searching I found out that you do
need some of the salts in there and
something like tomato is does not do
well on the gel and gums because it
doesn't have those calcium and magnesium
ions available to it so we end up having
to use an Audrey based for that but
again it's a chemical and a physical a
lot of it has to do with concentration
you know we look at that also not to sit
tight regard to your charcoal I can see
what you put that into pulling up some
of the finolex but doesn't it also
buying some of the hormone materially it
does right so with rear if we're working
with the medium and we see that you know
IA a works really well I'm sorry sorry
I'm sorry so I'm so Peter was wondering
you asked about the activated charcoal
that it can also bind some of the
hormones in the medium and it does so we
find that it will work out a system and
we find out that something like I ate a
certain concentration works really well
but if we then decide there's some
browning or we want routing and we
switched to using activated charcoal we
don't see the same response and you know
as we did with the original
concentration so then we have to bump
that up and look at other concentration
so yeah it can have an effect does
edina new species in North leave that
you're doing and I asked because they
say in my butterflies are declining
because people are destroying roughly in
their house oh okay yeah I don't know if
it does on other other milkweeds I know
that it uses that one primarily but I
don't know I don't know about the others
but but I'm planting it in my garden now
so I'm trying to I'm trying to help out
and yeah they're very pretty the very
beautiful but think people think it me
know it can be a weed but on the South
garden spread on the right across the
street has violent no please it's just
feeling the right stuff oh oh yeah
you're pretty messy too I don't mind
anything for the monarch yeah that's
right yeah exactly so Gina's asking
about ploidy level in the plant material
and when we go through that callous and
regeneration can that have an effect in
the end product and yes it can and some
plant species are more prone to it than
others so you'll see I think something
like pineapple well you'll see more of a
ploidy problem and regeneration and
transformation and some other systems
but with some with some people are doing
is looking at during chromosome counts
you're doing some sort of analysis to
see what the ploidy level is in the in
the resulting plants so do you have to
be aware of that for some plant species
because it can it can be an issue does
that answer your questions that you kind
of Apollo to ever use palm to
get a half for you can we do so I didn't
talk about that but we have done
cultures to be able to get halfway
material and using pollen or culturing
anthers at a certain stage of where the
pollen development so we did we had a
project with rice we were developing
haploids and actually I was talking with
a great breeder just yesterday who asked
me if we would consider doing that with
grape is looking at haploids for great
because i'm using a pollen system
because your grape is such a
heterozygous material it makes it
difficult but we're both sequencing and
for doing their work but if they had a
half way type great that it would really
help advance their work so so yes
definitely that will take some work to
try to get that I did Mays is an
undergraduate and that was enough of an
exposure to maize now the problem so
actually yeah astute area now but
actually actually I kind of enjoyed it
uh-huh because we at certain times of
the year they would pull everybody in
into a lab was an undergraduate work
study student and for maize the starting
material are immature embryos from and
you have to have the plants at a certain
stage to have these immature ears and
then what you do is you cut the kernels
and just go in you scoop out a little
immature embryo and it depends on how
it's you know oriented that you'll get
the right type of callous and when we
started our transformation service
someone David Stern said what about
doing maize and so uh that's really
tricky because you basically have to
dedicate greenhouse space to have the
plans to be able to do get your ears to
get your immature embryos so it kind of
becomes a financially difficult space
difficult to be able to do mais si but
you know and sometimes you grow those
plants and they don't have any requests
for doing the transformations but you
need to have that constant supply of
ears
yeah it's something genetic and
physiological about about maze versus
suit area yes and rice you can start
with mature seed so mature seed you
culture like setaria and you get that
you know you get that embryogenic
callous from it so it asked me have you
considered doing immature embryos from
setaria you saw how small those seats
are and i said i think i'd have a mutiny
on my hands in the lab if i ask people
to take immature embryos out of those
small seeds but fortunately like rice
immature seeds for Terry yeah we did
yeah we just did rice as part of an NSF
project a number of years ago but I
haven't been asked on otherwise here
yeah so nobody has asked us to do it so
so and what we did when we know when
David asked me to start up the
transformation services part of my
research program I talked to the project
leaders to pti and I said what are you
interested in your what you know what
type of crops it would be important for
you and we based it on their interest
first and since that time we've done
work for people with a Cornell and also
outside of Cornell that rice hasn't been
one of those
yes
great I'm sure there is i just don't
know if anyone has looked at it because
like in rice they've shown and in maize
as well as cystic you tell them where
the callous originates from so I'm sure
there's got to be a particular cell type
in that connective tissue oh that's
interesting mmhmm yeah so there must be
something to that for their very well
I've been left field but in in March it
was announced that all cultivated sweet
potatoes after jeans for agrobacterium
in I was throughout the war don't so
they must own it was late for its
thousands of years ago that it got
infected what possible advantage could I
agrobacterium pack i agree i wondered
the same you know what you know what was
it through another wild species but the
more cultivate oh so I'm sorry I'm sorry
I get so excited there was a because
there was a recent paper that showed
actually some the international potato
center where they were looking at sweet
potato and doing a kind of transcription
profiling to find out and they found
sequences from agrobacterium in some of
the sweet potatoes I think it tested
like 300 different types of sweet potato
if you want 291 every variety that they
that was a cultivated Brian not the wild
mm-hmm so there must have been some you
know I don't know if the cultivated ones
or amethyst wild ones had some sort of
resistance to the infection your
cultivated ones that resistance broke
down and then they were infected I don't
know if there's an evolutionary benefit
you know for the for the agrobacterium
and the wild sweet particular cultivated
but I got you know I was happy because I
thought okay what are they going to do
about GMOs now you know what sweet
potatoes and they have these components
of agrobacterium how are they going to
classify are they going to classify that
so it was interesting yeah mm-hmm he has
incorporated into the genome all right
oh really there's at least five
different segments of the Oak post
that's now integrated into the mistletoe
Gina I understand it it might be this
kind of notion of recognize himself
alone oh okay yeah that could be oh
that's a grizzly how easy or sweet
potatoes to try and spoil them hahaha
would say could be easy just get the
tuber mix it with a girl you're done oh
yeah get plants back from it but um but
we haven't work with sweet potato but I
think certain species are easier than
others but it might be more amenable to
it thank you everyone this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu